dissimulés dans les hauteurs de alleron
maya à la pointe sud ouest de l'arabie
saoudite
ces soldats saoudiens garde un oeil
constant sur le yémen le terrain
vallonné permettent à l'ennemi de se
terrer calme et trompeurs nous dit on la
nuit surtout les tireurs embusqués des
milices houthistes manifeste de leur
présence ce qui nous inquiète c'est
qu'ils traversent notre frontière et
atteignent nos forces défensives alors
on tente par tous les moyens de les en
empêche ces moyens imposants ont été
déployés d'urgence après que les milices
des outils et chassé par les armes le
gouvernement du yemen poussant l'arabie
saoudite à prendre la tête d'une
coalition de neuf pays arabes pour
contrer l'offensive houthistes c'est
maylis quand ils ont renversé le
gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont mis la
main sur tout ce qui est matériel de
guerre tous ces équipements de l'armée
deux semaines avant le lancement des
opérations
ils ont conduit un exercice de manoeuvre
sur nos frontières sud
un geste menaçant pour l'arabie saoudite
qui partagent quelques 800 km avec le
nord du yémen
le château fort des outils
c'est la toute première fois que
l'arabie saoudite permet un accès à ses
troupes qui sont aux toutes premières
lignes de défense du territoire saoudien
depuis le début de l'opération le 26
mars dernier
dans ce village qui longe la frontière
on pourrait vite oublié que l'arabie
saoudite est en guerre chez ses voisins
enfin presque
nous n'avons pas peur d'eux mohamed
on entend parfois des explosions mais
nous sommes bien protégés la fin
annoncée des bombardements aériens
n'exclut pas la poursuite de certaines
opérations militaires prévient la
coalition à preuve elle a frappé
plusieurs positions les outils encore
aujourd'hui pour le moment ses troupes
saoudiennes n'ont pas reçu l'ordre de
passer à une attaque terrestre au yémen
elle reste donc retrancher quelques 5 km
de la frontière d'où elles tirent sur
des positions yéménite
les soldats iront t'il plus avant
ramener la bataille au sol comporte des
risques d'enlisement important le lumen
s'est taillé la réputation d'être le
cimetière des envahisseurs étrangers et
pourrait bien devenir à l'arabie
saoudite
ce que le vietnam a été aux etats-unis
seul ou appuyés par d'autres pays
membres de la coalition
l'armée saoudienne se dit prête à une
intervention terrestre
cette adoption il est toujours valable
nous avons les moyens et il les force et
la capacité de mener ce genre d d'action
on doit pas refaire l'histoire
le vietnam s'est levé et nam
l'afghanistan c'est le cas stan et le
yémen pourrait-on ajouter c'est le yémen
un vaste territoire souvent
inhospitalier où tout le monde ou
presque possède une arme entre les
milices les tribus l'armée divisée sans
oublier al-qaïda et le groupe armé état
islamique
une invasion terrestre par ces soldats
saoudiens seraient au mieux périlleuse
pour leur vie mais aussi pour la
réputation et les ambitions politiques
de leur pays
ici marie fb d'un radio canada à la
frontière de l'arabie saoudite et du
yémen